bonsoir thomas comment l'administration
maiden agit-elle sur ce dossier épineux
bonsoir stéphanie et bien quelques
heures seulement après le début des
manifestations à cuba on avait déjà des
réactions américaines
des réactions qui s'enchaînent depuis ce
dimanche avec d'abord le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale puis une membre du
département d'état américain est encore
tout récemment le porte parole du
département d'état net price qui appelle
dit il les dirigeants de pub à faire
preuve de retenue et à respecter la voix
du peuple en ouvrant tous les moyens de
communication en ligne et hors ligne
voilà le genre de déclaration qui sont
donc régulièrement délivré par les
autorités américaines même le président
américain joe biden a pris position
publiquement il ya quelques jours je
propose de l'écouter
je veux commencer par reconnaître les
remarquables manifestations qui ont lieu
à cuba que le peuple cubain exigent sa
libération d'un régime autoritaire et je
ne pense pas que nous ayons vécu quelque
chose comme cette manifestation depuis
très très longtemps et je dirais même
jamais et les etats unis se tiennent aux
côtés du peuple cubain alors qu'ils font
valoir leurs droits universels
ce que nous appelons le gouvernement
quand le gouvernement de cuba à
s'abstenir de toute violence ou de
tenter de faire taire la voix du peuple
de reebok alors la rapidité de la
réaction américaine contraste quelque
peu avec d'autres sujets si on prend
l'exemple de la situation en colombie où
il ya aussi des manifestations violentes
depuis plusieurs semaines les états unis
n'avaient pas été aussi prompts à
condamner publiquement ce qu'il se
déroule en colombie il faut dire que l
administration de la maison blanche
soutient le président colombien en place
alors pour les autorités cubaines il
s'agit là d'une nouvelle illustration de
l'interventionnisme américain selon le
chef de la diplomatie cubaine et bien et
washington soutient d'une façon ou d'une
autre la campagne numérique
sos cuba c'est un hashtag qui a été
beaucoup utilisés par les manifestants
que ce soit à cuba mais aussi au sein de
la communauté cubaine qui vit
aux etats unis et puis pour le président
de cuba miguel diaz cannelle
les etats unis sont en grande partie
responsables de la situation dans le
pays parce qu'ils ont en mille en place
ce fameux blocus économique
ecoutez-le tous ces processus que nous
avons essayé d'affronter deux vaincus
face à une politique d' asphyxie
économique pour provoquer des troubles
sociaux dans le pays ont des effets
cumulatifs et je crois précisément
aujourd'hui les problèmes que nous
vivons sont liés à ces processus
alors pour le secrétaire d'état anthony
blinken il s'agit d'une grave erreur ce
sont ces mots que de blâmer les états
unis pour une quelconque implication
dans la situation à cuba mais il faut
quand même rappeler que l'embargo qui
est en place depuis maintenant 60 ans a
été condamné à de très nombreuses
reprises par la communauté
internationale il faut aussi rappeler
que joe biden lors de la dernière
campagne présidentielle avait fait une
promesse celle de revenir sur la
politique mise en place par donald trump
à l'égard de cuba une politique très
dure mais selon les informations de cnn
et bien les équipes de joe biden planche
toujours sur la bonne stratégie à
adopter pour ce dossier un dossier
particulièrement délicat dès qu'on parle
de cuba ici aux etats unis cela a fait
ressortir les vieux réflexes anti
communiste notamment auprès des élus
républicains ils sont très durs ils sont
un discours très agressif depuis
plusieurs jours on en pense notamment à
certains élus républicains de floride où
vit évidemment une grande communauté
cubaine je vous dirais par exemple le la
teneur des discours de tête cruz qui est
sénateur républicain du texas qui est
d'origine cubaine qui exhorte
l'administration de joe biden à tenir
une position très sévère à l'endroit du
pouvoir cubain
merci
et thomas abonnés